we've seen a lot of footage from Captain
America Civil War through trailers and
TV spots throughout all of this there's
one character and plot point that
remains a mystery Daniel Bruhl is
playing a character known as Zemo with
no information released about his
character many have been asking who the
heck is emo we won't reveal his full
role in a movie but we will tell you
about the character from the Marvel
Comics the current days emo is helmut
Zemo the thirteenth Zemo before we get
into his story let's look back at his
father dr. Heinrich Zemo this Zemo was
one of Hitler's greatest scientists
after conducting tests on and killing a
large number of innocent civilians Zemo
began to wear a pinkish purplish hood to
conceal his identity while building
weapons for the Nazis he developed an
extremely strong adhesive known as
adhesive X because it obviously be used
for evil purposes Captain America
attempted to put an end to its
development unfortunately when he threw
his shield at Heinrich he shattered the
back containing adhesive X it poured all
over Zemo permanently gluing his mask to
his face Zemo later got revenge on
Captain America and Bucky by capturing
and strapping them to an experimental
airplane which would explode over the
Atlantic Bucky was thought killed as cap
ended up frozen in ice for decades upon
Captain America's return in a modern day
Heinrich was outraged over his foes
returned he formed a masters of evil but
was killed in a rockslide he
inadvertently caused while fighting
Captain America years later Captain
America and Falcon were attacked by
someone calling himself the Phoenix cap
was strapped above of that of adhesive X
the Phoenix revealed he was helmet Zemo
he blamed Captain America for his father
changing from a brilliant man into an
abusive monster having adhesive export'
on him during the encounter helmet ended
up falling into the bat himself leading
cap and Falcon to believe he was dead
helmet returned dressed in an outfit
similar to his father's he managed to
escape the VAT of adhesive X through a
secret hatch and survived due to the
specially insulated suit he wore
unfortunately because he wasn't wearing
his mask his face was pretty messed up
Zima revealed he figured out captain
his true identity and plan to strike at
his loved ones he later formed the new
masters of evil and attacked the benders
mansion Zemo was involved in several
attempts to take over the world over the
years when the Avengers and Fantastic
Four disappeared he launched his
greatest scheme a new group of
protectors calling themselves the
Thunderbolts debut it turned out it was
really Zemo and the Masters of evil
pretending to be heroes the others
enjoyed their new roles and Zemo was
ousted as their leader
Zemo recently tried to take over the
world once again by gaining control over
a cosmic cube that had grown sentience
and taken the form of a little girl his
plans were thwarted by Captain America
and the Avengers
Zemo was teleported away by the Cosmic
Cube and remains at large
Zemo is capable of a lot of things be
sure to check out Captain America Civil
War to see what he's responsible for in
a Cinematic Universe